ich will mal versuchen einen blick auf
putin und russland zu werfen das dürfe
man nicht vergessen denn da gibt es
glaube ich aus meiner sicht in sehr
interessante verschiebung wir haben uns
ja hier angewöhnt da war es geradezu
anbot ihn als den kühl kalkulierenden
überlegenen strategen zu sehen der sogar
die westlichen reaktionen auf den
ukraine krieg ganz weitsichtig in seine
strategie eingeplant hat welch ein
irrtum putin hat im ukraine krieg das
exakte gegenteil dessen angerichtet was
er eigentlich erreichen wollte denn
putin zerstört auch russland und das
möchte ich mal mit ein paar stichworte
unterlegen denn ich glaube dass da seine
machtbasis im eigenen land langsam
erodiert russland ist in allen belangen
geschwächt die ukraine aber wurde zur
selbstbewussten nation geformt von ihm
die ist militärisch vielleicht zu
besiegen mit äußerster brutalität aber
sie ist nicht auszulöschen die nato ist
einig und brutal schon wie lange nicht
mehr schafft im osten neue militärische
strukturen finnland und schweden denken
an ein nato-beitritt die nato
osterweiterung ist rückblickend
gerechtfertigt das pazifistische
deutschland rüstet auf russland ist in
der welt isoliert wie noch nie ein paria
staat in den un hat es noch belarus
syrien eritrea und nordkorea an seiner
seite ich bitte um zu leben dass das
ablesen kann ich mir nicht alles merken
die russische wirtschaft fast in den
abgrund zentralbank und banken sind
gelähmt die börsen geschlossen der rubel
ist um 70 prozent eingebrochen
geldautomaten und supermärkte leeren
sich die staats pleite rückt näher
westliche konzerne verlassen in großer
zahl russland der besten löst sich von
putins öl und gas damit verarmt das land
nord stream zwei da bin ich überzeugt
wird niemals in betrieb gehen putin
freundliche oligarchen sind unter druck
ihre vermögen sind eingefroren ihre
jacken und jets an die kette gelegt
russland russen können im westen keinen
urlaub mehr machen dass es nicht ganz
unbedeutend ihre kreditkarten gelten im
ausland nicht mehr isolation auch in
sport und kultur der russische fußball
spielt nirgends mehr mit anna netrebko
singt nicht im westen putin kritische
russen protestieren oder fliehen nach
finnland in der raumfahrt zerbricht die
zusammenarbeit mit dem westen gibt es
überhaupt einen einzigen aspekt einen
positiven aspekt für russland aus diesem
klick ich kann keinen erkennen denn
nicht mal die landnahme in der ukraine
funktioniert ja ich sehe das wie einen
erweiterten suizid putin bringt sich
selbst um und nimmt sein land mit jeder
kann erkennen auch jeder in russland ein
guter präsident ist er nicht mehr selbst
wenn er noch beute macht am ende den
ukraine krieg hat er verloren
also ich würde sagen dass war auch ich
möchte jetzt nicht ein thema direktor
bedienen aber es war eigentlich auch
fast wie ein cd dafür warum die sanktion
anscheinend doch nicht das alleinige
allheilmittel sind war auch passiert ja
nicht viel bislang doch was ist es ist
doch nicht jede menge rück märkte und in
russland zu merken nun jede menge an
putin immer noch krieg ja das ist nicht
der punkt putin wird immer krieg machen
der geht unter am ende das ist ihm
völlig wurscht wie seine bevölkerung
leidet die frage ist ob es im
machtsystem risse gibt und da haben wir
heute das erste mal gelesen
interessanterweise dass zwei führende
geheimdienstleute unter hausarrest
gestellt worden sind von ihm und das ein
paar generelle der armee gedeckelt
worden sind also da gibt es schon
meinungsunterschiede aufbrechende
gegensätze darauf setze ich setze nicht
dass es eine erhebung des russischen
volkes gibt dass damit können wir nicht
rechnen aber das ist im machtsystem ein
paar leute gibt es sich überlegen
protein abzuräumen bevor russland am
boden liegt sie sind eher russischer
herkunft mit dem ist spanisch russisch
ukrainischer und da ist natürlich die
frage auch für mich wie sehen sie denn
die lage also bricht der bericht die
zustimmung für ihn wirklich weg oder
glauben wir dass hier und sagen ja dass
der wird jetzt so eingekesselt der
verliert alle seine zuneigung des volkes
also zerstört putin wirklich gerade
russland
und die frage ob putin russland zerstört
das kann ich nur mit ja beantworten
bezüglich der zustimmung ist es alles
ein bisschen komplizierter die älteren
leute die vor allem staatliche
fernsehsender gucken und politisches
interesse haben sind meines erachtens
nicht mehr zu retten die glauben
tatsächlich alles was aus dem fernseher
kommt dann gibt es natürlich sehr viele
apolitische russen wie in jedem land die
sagen politik geht mich nichts an
vielleicht schadet der auch unserem land
aber ich mische mich da nicht ein meine
hoffnung habe ich gesetzt und auch in
den gesprächen die ich hatte mit jungen
russen das sind die jungen leute die die
zukunft des landes eigentlich sind die
gebildet sind die ein demokratisches und
freies russland wollen und für die die
welt gerade wirklich untergeht also ein
freund von mir aus moskau
theaterregisseur schrieb mir kürzlich
facebook messenger
dass das das schlimmste ereignis in der
jüngsten russischen geschichte ist das
ist wirklich das das ende für alle ist
die erkennt inklusive ihm selbst das
sind die kreativen leute das sind die
leute die ein anderes land wollen heute
habe ich gesprochen mit einer studentin
aus moskau die sagt sie hatte noch nie
so viel angst wie heute es ist es geht
ja nicht nur um eine wirtschaftliche
situation dass die leute sich kaum mehr
lebensmittel leisten können es geht doch
einfach darum dass sie angst hat in
moskau mitten auf der straße
festgehalten zu werden von der polizei
weil sie vielleicht irgendwie rebellisch
aussieht dass dann ein polizeibeamter
kommt und die handy durch suche nach
irgendwelchen jets nach nach dem wort
krieg invasion angriff und dass sie dann
ohne jeden rechtsgrund festgehalten wird
verprügelt und traumatisiert also
russland verliert tatsächlich seine
zukunft in dem es seine jugend verliert
das muss man so sagen muss man auch
denken an die jungen leute die an die
front geschickt werden und aktuell
immobilien in mobilen krematorien
verheizt dass das sind sehr viele
aspekte die hinzu kommen zu dem was du
gesagt hast du ja ich erinnere daran als
die ddr zusammengebrochen es war der
geheimdienstchef markus wolf auf seiten
der revolution so was gibt es in solchen
situationen immer wo leute sich
überlegen im machtsystem wie sie ihren
eigenen kopf retten können und sich
erinnern wie sie selbst gedemütigt
worden sind wir haben doch erlebt wie
putin seinen geheimdienstchef im
sogenannten sicherheitsrat als sie
miteinander geredet haben gedemütigt hat
weil der die falsche ansage gemacht hat
er sollte nur sagen wir erkennen jetzt
die republiken in der ost ukraine hat
aber gesagt ich bin dafür dass wir die
in russland der integrieren das sollte
er noch gar nicht das steht hier nicht
zur debatte hat putin gesagt also da ist
die inszenierung irgendwie auseinander
gefallen so was vergessen die leute
nicht falls der mann immer noch im amt
ist hat er das nicht vergessen
herr mählich blick da natürlich zu ihm
ja es ist auch eine schwierige debatte
die jetzt in deutschland läuft ist das
ein krieg von putin oder ist ein krieg
der der russen oder russlands und also
irgendwie und ich glaube dass das nicht
nur der boutique krieg ist leider manche
wollen das vereinfachen hier auch
bundespräsident steinmeier hat gestern
eine rede gehalten wo er sagt es ist nur
der putin schrecklich ja aber nicht kein
krieg der russen und da glaube ich man
sollte das schon ein bisschen
differenzierter diesen blick geworfen
dann klar das was was sie zu recht sagen
die menschen wurden summiert da wurden
gehirne gewaschen und zwar seit
mindestens acht jahren seit der
klimadiskussion hat man immer wieder im
fernsehen dass das eine die eine these
gehört die ukraine sind ein erzfeind die
müssen vernichtet werden die müssen
entnazifiziert werden all die lügen die
jetzt auch heute weil sie die politik
von pudding entscheiden und das bedeutet
dass die russen man möchte daran nicht
glauben man glaubt dass wir uns
natürlich und die jungen wahrscheinlich
sind daher nicht so anfällig aber für
für eine mehrheit der russen ist es
wahrscheinlich so dass sie hinter
büschen sich gestellt haben oder sie
wurden gezwungen weil sie diese
rückendeckung zu geben und das macht
auch die lage noch gefällig hat es ist
nicht so dass das buch ja irgendwie es
ist nicht der putin alleine und deswegen
man muss nach instrumenten suchen wie
man das thema auch so angeht dass das
wir dieser komplexität auch erkennen und
ja immer gut gelegen ist ein rechner sie
haben eben eher angesprochen dass das ja
auch das russische ist und wann ist
differenziert betrachten muss ich kann
erst einmal verstehen ich kann's auch
großartig mario czaja der
generalsekretär zum beispiel union hat
sich auch dafür ausgesprochen dass nicht
alles russische putin ist und es
passieren wirklich schon in deutschland
auch schlimme sachen in den hass gegen
russland zeigen also es gab eine
leiterin einer klinik in münchen die
plötzlich in einem schreiben keine
russischen patienten mehr wahrnehmen
wollte mitten in diesem land in
deutschland es gab einen ein geschäft in
oberhausen wo dann farbe dagegen gewohnt
wurde eine russische supermarkt und das
macht mir ganz große angst weil ich ganz
klar sagen muss ist dafür jetzt nicht in
deutschland alles russische entstehen
und deswegen würde ich schon sagen putin
ist nicht russland ja das stimmt dass
das was sie meinen also keiner ist ja so
diese anfeindungen oder der angriff war
dass das die sind natürlich zu
verurteilen seien kein thema aber ich
meine also für die politik also für für
für für die politiker in deutschland da
müsste man doch einen anderen blick
darauf werfen und nicht nur jetzt da er
sich gedanken machen wie können kann man
putin treffen wie kann man ihn reichen
kann man nicht überzeugen wie kann man
ihn mag weil sie wie kann man ihn dazu
bewegen dass er diesen krieg stopp
sondern man muss auch man muss auch man
muss auch ob die menschen einwirken und
unsere und nicht nur glauben dass die
menschen da jetzt quasi neutrale haltung
einnehmen das sind doch die russen die
jetzt in der ukraine die panzer beginnen
die die russen die jetzt zu
führen und die jetzt bomben auf die
zivilisten abwerfen das heißt das alles
ist ein sehr komplexes thema und das und
die telefonate die abgehört werden die
soldaten sprechen mit ihren müttern mit
ihren frauen und das spürt man dass sie
das auch unterstützen ja und das was sie
dass die erzählen was sie in der ukraine
also machen gegen zivilisten schießen
usw das alles das wissen wir und das
erfüllt also mich mit angst also wie
tief dieses land jetzt fallen musste
damit wir so
sprachlos sind ausweisen kann man ja mal
antue da muss ich ihnen widersprechen
in allen solchen diktaturen und das ist
inzwischen klare diktaturen russland
geht es darum den kopf zu beseitigen es
gibt immer viele menschen die mit laufen
das war in nazi deutschland auch so wo
vermutlich mehrheiten bis zum kriegsende
hinter hitler gestanden haben aber es
ging darum hitler zu beseitigen und da
erreicht in diesem fall hätte eine
erfolgreiche bombe gereicht um den krieg
zu beenden weil die großen teile der
wehrmacht sofort bereit wären bereit
gewesen wären für waffenstillstand da
geht es nicht darum das ist einfach
immer so also die viele leute sind irre
geführt die die laufen hinter ihrem
führer her die glauben alles was der
sagt dass es umgekehrt noch ein argument
mehr den zu beseitigen finde ich
hier würde ich gerne ich habe länger
nichts mehr hinter mir gehört das ist
aber paulus noch reich machen manchmal
sorgen bei eben auch noch eine rennbahn
aber immer noch da du dich einmal
einschalten eine diskussion bitte
was mich am meisten beschäftigt gerade
ist die frage und glaube ich die auch
viele zuschauer interessiert und
vielleicht kann uns andere wenig da
weiterhelfen was hat jetzt dieser
schulter besucher eigentlich bei punkten
gebracht oder nicht gebracht und was
wissen sie darüber und inwieweit steht
die ukrainische regierung jetzt mit
schröder in kontakt weil politiker hatte
ja gemeldet dass dieser besuch zurück
geht auf einen ukrainischen abgeordneten
unter schröder auch am rande einer
ukrainischen delegation in istanbul
gewesen sei und dann von dort nach
moskau zu fliegen und es schien
sozusagen die mission zu sein putin
davon zu überzeugen dass er direkt mit
seinen ski verhandelt was wissen sie
darüber
ja das ist
ein spannendes thema muss man sagen und
wurde auch sehr gezielt gesetzt
und das freut mich dass schröder
jetzt bild tv zuschauer ist wo er dann
das verfolgt was was hier besprochen wie
er ist ja geraten und
das war eben ein ganz spontaner gedanken
eigentlich ein 1 1 ein kreativer
vorschlag wieso sollten wir herrn
schröder jetzt abschreiben auch wenn
wenn wir gesagt wenn ich persönlich
nicht viel respekt vor diesem mann habe
aber trotzdem vielleicht hat er noch
eine letzte mittel haben als er es ihrem
ruf gefolgt ich kann mir das auch gut
vorstellen so viele nachts mit von
vielen politikern geschaut der mensch
aber dass das hat noch mal ja das wissen
nicht aber aber was was heute noch mal
ganz konkret wenn man ganz konkret weil
das muss man ja mittlerweile wissen also
politiker berichtet diese abgeordnete
sei mehr oder weniger auf auftrag von
oder in kontakt zumindest auch mit dem
präsidenten gewesen dafür habe ich
bislang weiterhin keine bestätigung aus
ukrainischen quelle ich weiß nicht wie
es ihnen geht ob sie damit ich darf im
moment noch keine einzelheiten verraten
aber
so weit kann ich schon sagen dieser
vorschlag oder dieser idee kam von herrn
schröder in den letzten tagen das war
keine bitte oder von von der ukrainische
seite sondern das war eben schröder hat
sich gemeldet nicht direkt indirekt aber
immerhin und und fiel direkt gemeldet er
hat über über
gewisse kontakte die auch kontakte zur
ukraine haben und es wurde signalisiert
nachhilfe dass er bereit wäre mal zu
versuchen und das heißt das kann ich
heute bestätigen das heißt das war nicht
eine initiative aus kiel sondern
umgekehrt und das heißt das dass herr
schröder vielleicht tatsächlich noch
versuchte auch seinen sein ansehen ein
bisschen aufzupolieren und doch einen
anderen platz in der geschichte für sich
zu entdecken dabei bleiben wir werden
übrigens darauf direkt jetzt
zurückkommen ich muss ihn aber in
rechnung abgeben ich muss aber wir
bleiben bei diesem thema also direkt
nach der kleinen werbeunterbrechung sind
wir zurück und wir werden weiter darüber
sprechen mit hair make bis gleich
wir haben gerade mit hennig heißt
darüber debattiert und wir waren
eigentlich schon fast dabei ist
herauszufinden sind bleiben wird es auch
bei dem thema wenig über wessen kontakte
wie kann das treffen mit herr schröder
zustande sie sind ja ein mann der
offenen worte
ja also ich kann nur soweit sorgen dass
das über linie verlag lief das ganze das
heißt gewisse berichte kann ich auch
bestätigen aber vor allem geht es darum
dass diese initiative von herrn schröder
kam
auch wenn auch wie gesagt auch wenn man
dann nicht viel hoffnung gibt aber das
was was wir auch in diesem studio wir
besprochen haben erst vor einer woche
das gilt nämlich es gibt nicht so viele
menschen weltweit und auch in
deutschland vielleicht die diesen
persönlichen draht so helmut ihn haben
und deswegen hat auch vielleicht erst
einmal das gespürt ja vielleicht hat er
diese kraft mal vielleicht traut er sich
mal nach moskau zu fliegen und wir alle
bereit herbei ja
ja ja aber wenn ich das ja ganz
wichtiger punkt weil bislang ist ja
sozusagen muss manchmal zusammenfassen
für die zuschauer die lage die
nachrichtlichen lage so dass bislang die
menschen davon ausgegangen sind so
scheint es zumindest schröder
dargestellt zu haben wir wissen nicht
was die quelle von politik ist das
ukraine auf ihn zugegangen sind sie
sagen jetzt das war genau anders herum
und das ist ja schon ein sehr wichtiger
hintergrund wo man jetzt auch die frage
stellen muss welche motivation hatte er
schröder offenbar angespornt durch sie
herr botschafter nämlich sie haben genau
das bei viertel nach acht vor ungefähr
zehn tagen gesagt dass sie das gut
finden wenn das passiert dennoch wenn
die initiative von schröder jetzt
ausging was glauben sie ist oder war
seine motivation das zu tun geht es
darum so zu sagen klar zu machen und zu
versuchen sein image wiederherzustellen
oder glauben sie dass er tatsächlich ein
ehrliches interesse bzw
das gefühl hat dass er bei putin etwas
verändern kann weil wir müssen ja mal
sagen stand jetzt hat er nichts
verändert also wladimir putin hat
angekündigt nach dem treffen wir fast
mal kurz zusammen das 16 1000 kämpfer
von assad in die ukraine kommen könnten
er hat möglicherweise soldaten von
lukaschenko angeworben die kommen sollen
oder lukas schinko tritt im krieg ein
und die kriege der krieg geht hier
weiter also da ist ja auch noch nichts
erreicht worden oder
also mal sehen also ich kann insoweit
sagen dass eventuell morgen wir auch
direkt von der schwede hören werden also
was was waren die ergebnisse dieser
dieses treffens mit herrn putin und was
die motivation betrifft das was bau
jetzt fragte ich glaube das war beides
ja sowohl das image vielleicht ein
bisschen aufzupolieren als auch
vielleicht doch ein beitrag zu leisten
dass dieser krieg zu ende geht mal sehen
inwieweit er erfolgreich war bei seinen
kumpel putin aber zumindest das ist und
sie wissen ist doch schon oder ich habe
das gefühl sie wissen dass schröder
morgen etwas sagen wird in welche
richtung es gehen wird wissen sie das
ist weiß nicht nur und also ehrlich
gesagt also ich weiß dass herr schröder
bereit ist darüber zu berichten über
kanäle die jetzt quasi nichtöffentliche
laufen und das ist gut dass das man
zumindest fragen meister muss noch bei
bild live auftreten will also ob die
fläche la schröder ja ein interview mit
life führen man sagt ja dass das
wir machen da ich glück nicht ganz so
stark ihr recht bin ich nach vielleicht
komme ich noch in frage
wer nicht gerne rad ja wie du ihn fragen
du dir auch mal ein bisschen was mich
auch ein bisschen wasser angießen ich
glaube nicht dass eine so genannte
männerfreundschaft ausreicht um einen
krieg zu beenden das traue ich diesem
verhältnis nicht zu wenn er was
mitbringt ist es möglicherweise der
öffnungen des korridors aus mario pohl
dass dort die menschen abziehen können
und nicht beschlossen werden das könnte
ich mir schon eher vorstellen und dann
kommt aber schröder um aus seiner
vollkommenen isolation herauszukommen
nicht an der beantwortung der frage
vorbei ob er jetzt hat seine ämter in
den russischen energiekonzernen
verzichtet das ist die frage die er
persönlich beantworten muss und ich gebe
interessiert mich auch
seine ämter muss ich sagen nee am ende
wenn er zu den eigenen haus bekannt gibt
also welche welcher folge können
schröder verzeichnen ich schätze sie
ehrlich gesagt nicht als besonders hoch
ein er ist er putins angestellte also
wenn wenn putin jemals auf die leute
gehört hätte die ihn umgeben die vielen
arbeiten wäre wahrscheinlich nie in der
ukraine engagiert und jetzt jetzt kann
auch nicht schröder sagen du wo war das
das war aber eine ganz blöde idee hol
mal deine truppen daraus das ist die
frage ob sich schultern ein propaganda
konzept einbauen lassen kann ja
möglicherweise würden wirklich
wahrscheinlich werden sie es tun ich
noch einmal auf die auf die sichtweise
von ihnen ein wenig ich fand es spannend
ich sah sie ihn mit ihnen die sendungen
habe gefordert man muss ihm quasi alles
wegnehmen und der soll keine
staatsgelder mal bekommen der schröder
und ich bin auch immer noch meine dieser
meinung und ich finde auch dieses wort
angestellter putin sehr passend ich
persönlich sie haben mich ja damals
total damit überrascht dass sie für
diesen dialog waren und dass er dorthin
fliegt
wie sich denn davon versprochen als sie
die idee bei 48 gesagt haben dass
schröder hinreisen sollte was war ihre
motivation dahinter was haben sie
geglaubt könnte schröder erreichen also
wir suchen auch ich persönlich hier in
deutschland menschen die fähig und
bereit wären zu helfen diesen krieg zu
beenden und das was ich bis heute
gespürt und gehört habe keiner keiner
scheint bereit zu sein wieder in die
regierung noch in den wirtschaftskreisen
die auch jetzt tatsächlich denn man hat
ja seit jahren seit jahrzehnten diese
brücke nach moskau gebaut und diesen
diese diese vertraulichkeit auch so
geschätzt und auch das wurde auch immer
wieder gepriesen wie sind die deutschen
wir haben diesen sonderweg nach nach
nach moskau und jetzt wo diese krieg kam
dann sind alle weg alle friedenstauben
alle die quasi sich gebracht haben dass
sie dann so nah am boden sind und
deswegen war auch dieser gedanke
natürlich ist die hoffnung dann nicht
sehr groß aber immerhin wenn es gelingen
sollte zumindest die lage er ist ein
freund von ihm also die lage zu
beschreiben wie das ist ja das heißt es
ist vorbei er hat diesen krieg verloren
er kann dann vielleicht noch gesicht
waren ein bisschen etwas tun und da
könnte stroh oder vielleicht helfen wenn
eine waffenpause waffenruhe eingeführt
würde wenn wenn putin überzeugt dass er
sich mit salems betrifft also diese zwei
kleine schritte kleiner die sind die
werden auch nicht jünger schröder so
eine macht hat sondern besser waffenruhe
dass ich glaube ich nicht aber ich
glaube dass er ist einer der wenigen die
vielleicht vermuten auch die augen
öffnen können auf auf auf das desaster
dass herr putin angerichtet hat und auf
diese
ausweglosigkeit die härten hervor
verursacht hatte also dass das könnte
durchaus tun das heißt es geht um die
psychologisch es geht nicht darum dass
er weiß er ist er unterstellte also man
sagt der pudel von von putin es gab eine
reihe von synonymen die möchte ich nicht
verwenden weil es kommt darauf an was er
als person als mensch bewirken könnte
und da bin ich gespannt mit wasser
morgen super league wollen wir uns
nochmal brands einmal ein ende
ja ich finde meine sache sehr sehr
wichtig um das auch noch mal in den
zuschauern zu erklären noch einmal wir
wissen nicht was die quelle von politik
war aber in dem bericht und auch in
allen berichten die bislang über den
besuch beschrieben wurden wurde überall
zitiert das ist halt das ist die
ukrainische initiative gewesen sein das
ist von einem ukrainischen abgeordneten
kamen und dass schröder deshalb geflogen
ist und das ist schon einen sehr sehr
großen unterschied den wir jetzt
erfahren dadurch dass anträge der
ukrainische botschafter sagt nein es war
schröder der auf die ukraine zugekommen
ist und offenbar er zurückgekommen ist
auf einen vorschlag von anderen manic
bei viertel nach acht das erst gut fände
wenn das passieren würde aber dennoch
die initiative gegenüber der ukrainische
regierung kam von schröder und das ist
ein großer die richtung putin kam von
schröder und das ist ein sehr sehr
großer unterschied und man muss sich
fragen welche motive und welche
motivation dabei schröder dahinter
steckten und was das dann am ende für
das ergebnis bedeuten kann ich gegen
yannik recht wenn etwas erreicht würde
auch wenn es nur klein wäre und egal
welchen hintergrund schröder hat wäre
das gut aber wir müssen leider davon
ausgehen dass natürlich wladimir putin
auch das wieder nutzt für seine
propaganda möglicherweise dann dinge
verkündet werden die ehe verkündet
worden wären um schröder sozusagen einen
erfolg zu gönnen das muss man genau
unter diesem licht betrachtet finde man
muss bei schröder einfach unterstellen
dass er sehr leidet unter seiner
situation das hat er sich selber
zuzuschreiben
ja und wie stark er gelitten hat kann
man daran erkennen dass seine frühere
frau gesagt hat angesichts der
diskussion über die anerkennung der
ehrenbürgerschaft der stadt hannover man
solle ihn doch bitte nicht in einer
reihe mit adolf hitler stellen soweit
war das schon gekommen und das ist
natürlich für einen wie schröder als ein
tiefschlag der der der superklasse das
war auch nicht mitfühlend gemein von
seiner ehemaligen frau aus dieser lage
musste er dringend raus wenig der herr
schröder ist jetzt müssen eben
genau da ich wollte auch das thema
nämlich dieses foto von der aktuellen
frau
dem zusammen mal auch
genau was ich habe das erfunden als eine
schaurige komödie ehrlich gesagt ja
schröder hat sich mit seinen frauen aber
ist der instagram kaum von seiner frau
nicht immer eine schaurige komödie lässt
jetzt noch schauriger gefordert wird in
der indoor in der in der kurzärmligen
jacke beim kochen das ist zwar auch
schrecklich aber nicht schaurig aber zu
beten in moskau für den frieden das ist
irgendwie wie kann sie das herr neben
gewesen
all diese bilder ja die sind natürlich
haben schon einen eigenen wert ja
vielleicht gibt es dann eine
kunstgalerie werden fotos ausgestellt
hauptsache ist dass dass diese gespräche
die jetzt auf den weg gebracht wurden
und ich habe heute einen halben tag
verbracht um mit diesem abgeordneten
über den paul gerade gesprochen hat ich
habe mit ihm heute telefoniert den
ganzen tag und deswegen
die hoffnung ist nicht sehr groß aber
immerhin werde ich jetzt erzählen sie
uns den wahren inhalt das gespräch war
bitte ich muss auch sagen über das
wissen wer wirklich etwas passiert sein
und deine mal zurücknehmen
ich weiß was ist denn da rausgekommen
vielleicht etwas kleines nein also wir
wissen noch nicht dass das das sollte
quasi persönlich in einem persönlichen
gespräch mitgeteilt werden nicht
telefonisch und und solange das nicht
geschehen ist kann ich auch könnten noch
mehr sein können und was wenn es etwas
größeres wäre das für sie durchs land
heben und es nicht schröder überlassen
wenn schöner eine erklärung abgibt an
einer und eine eine änderung und eine
punktuelle an der russischen
kriegspolitik bekannt gibt dann ist es
eher ein korridor für die absuche der
zivilbevölkerung irgendwas kurzer
waffenstillstand in mario pohl aber
nicht eine grundsätzliche strategische
änderung des kriegs kurses das lässt
sich putin nicht nehmen ja also ich
denke schröder fühlt sich wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich sehr machtlos einmal
gegenüber putins politik dann natürlich
gegenüber den reaktionen in der
deutschen bevölkerung sogar bei seinen
eigenen angestellten die alle gekündigt
haben er ist nicht mehr einer der ihren
kanzler der spd also zum thema
motivation ich glaube panik ist ein
eigentlich ein sehr wichtiger begriff
den wir noch nicht er merkt alles um ihn
herum bricht zusammen und dann versucht
er noch das allerletzte um irgendwie die
wände zu bekommen auch wenn ich das
nicht für sehr realistisch halte das so
jan schröder kam auf instagram schöner
bilder kostet ist das andere aber hier
ist natürlich die person schröder im
mittelpunkt so wie er sich selbst
jedenfalls inszeniert ich unterstelle ja
dass er seine frau in dem hotel selbst
fotografiert hat
wird kemal gewesen sein und lass macht
die ganze sache doch ein bisschen seif
ich finde ich
also die situation können wir uns ja
alle dann mal möglich forscher er wird
wahrscheinlich öfter das nennt man
übrigens uni instagram husband also in
der in stil und sprache heißt das
institut im hass sind dh der schröder
wäre dann der in zug um hass und seiner
frau das machen aber viele männer mit
also da ist ja schon da nicht der
einzige ich glaube in der welt ja ich
würde gerne nochmal paul reinholen weil
ich bin auch der meinung war wir können
jetzt eigentlich noch nicht damit
anfangen kommen lassen oder
naja sagen wir so wenn es für den
frieden gut ist oder für schritte die
hier zur deeskalation
wirken wenn man wie ich das jetzt noch
nicht erzählt dann verstehe ich ihn wenn
man da etwas noch nicht öffentlich
machen will mich interessiert es
natürlich wahnsinnig und unsere
zuschauer sicherlich auch aber noch
einmal allein die tatsache dass das
ganze nicht von ukrainischer seite kam
sondern von schröder selbst ist für mich
schon etwas sehr neues